hello everyone welcome to another
episode of Science and Technology Q&A
for kids and others I think the L of
2023 so let's see you know I I'm uh uh
I'm happy to try and answer questions
that are like uh things you wondered
about science technology that maybe
should have been in some class that
somebody could have taken at some time
but they either didn't take it or they
didn't understand what people had to say
I'm happy to try and address those kinds
of questions as well as kind of the uh
uh the more specific kinds of
things but let's
see
um anti is asking do we know enough of
neurobiology to assert that the human
brain works differently from machine
learning or AI model
model um well at some level it obviously
does because its underlying technology
is different the underlying technology
of uh uh any kind of AI machine Learning
System is a digital computer which is
based on semiconductors and electronics
and so on whereas the base technology
for our brains is
electrochemistry and although it's still
electrical signals the electrical
signals are generated in transmitted in
different ways it's also worth
remembering that the the uh kind of
energy budget is quite different in the
sense that um uh
for where and and sort of time budget
and so on I mean our neurons kind of
fire every tens some number of tens of
milliseconds so maybe a 100 times a
second or something like this uh whereas
in a computer we're routinely
having a billion operations per second
so the the time scales are different by
a factor of a million or so the thing
that our brains still very much have
over computers is that it tends to be
the case that most of the uh most of the
kind of components in a computer are
idle most of the time whereas in our
brains presumably most of the neurons
are doing something most of the time so
and and we managed to get away with
about 50 watts of power running our
brains um whereas the typical computer
well I suppose actually an interesting
question I actually don't know the
answer to this if you ran a computer as
slowly as our brains run uh how much
power would it take and I suspect the
answer is um that if you redesign the
computer to run as slowly as our brains
run that you could get away with using
vastly less power than modern computers
use to run the million times faster than
our
brains I think another feature of uh
well another thing about our brains is
that they are continually learning
whereas in current AI systems one mostly
has a time of training and then a time
of actually running or so-called
inference in inferring output from input
so to speak and those are two separate
things whereas for our brains those
things are are mixed
together I think that the um uh in terms
of another thing about things like well
a large language model or something like
chbt it has the feature that the input
comes in and it kind of trickles through
a few hundred layers of neurons and then
the output comes out and it says what
the next word should be and then the
whole cycle starts again and so the only
way that there sort of feedback from
what got gener generated to uh what will
be generated next is through this kind
of outer loop of oh this word got
produced now the whole input contains
that word as well let's Ripple through
the the neural net again and see what
comes out next whereas in our brains
there are many more nerve fibers we our
brains are not the same kind of
feedforward architecture where it's just
you start from sort of one end and then
things percolate through and then and
then you sort of use only use the the
output only in a kind of a small way to
determine what the next input will be
more it's a kind of a lots of two-way
connections and so on in our brains so
that's another another uh difference I
would say that the thing to recognize is
that one thing we learn from computers
is this idea of universal computation
this idea that even though the detailed
Hardware of two computers might be
different the programs they can run can
still be the same and that means it
becomes less important what the detailed
Hardware is what really matters is what
the structure of the software the
algorithms the methods and so on are and
I think the same is probably true of
brains that the details of whether some
particular
um uh some some uh the details of how
particular neurons work and the fact
that we have all these different kinds
of neurons and they have different
connectivity pattern and so on and uh
the details of that is probably less
important and that rather there are sort
of global features of how brains
generally work which are probably very
much in common between modern AI systems
and actual biological brains you know I
think I mentioned this before but one
sort of exercise that I've been
wondering about recently is this
question of okay so if our brains could
be scaled up to run a million times
faster to have many more neurons than we
actually have we have about 100 billion
neurons in our brains each one of which
has maybe a thousand connections maybe
10,000 connections so there's perhaps
some uh something like a a 100 trillion
Connections in our brains and so on
that's as compared to in in chat gbt at
least the original version there were
about uh 200 billion connections um in
that system but the question is as you
scale up the number of connections and
the number of neurons and so on how does
that affect the capabilities that that
uh that one has and it's sort of a a an
interesting and and uh sort of
interesting cautionary tale I suppose
that if you look at lower animals they
have smaller brains and sometimes they
have brains that are big because they
just have lots of nerve fibers coming in
from a very big creature like a whale or
something with lots of skin area and
such like but mostly they have smaller
brains and they're able to do less stuff
than we can do so the question becomes
well what happens if you scale the brain
up how much more stuff can you do what
are the qualitatively different things
that become possible you know I kind of
think I think I was mentioning this in
another another one of these live
streams that uh the fact that we humans
have about 50,000 words in in our
languages is probably a consequence of
the rough number of neurons that we have
in our brains and if we had many more
neurons we could deal with languages
that have many more words in them what
consequence would that have I'm not sure
we would have more kinds of Concepts
that we could that we would
intrinsically know about you know in a
sense the words in our language are the
concepts that we intrinsically know
about and I suppose as you try and think
about things there's sort of this
question of you're thinking about them
in terms of Concepts if you had more
Concepts it's sort of a more you you you
don't have to make as big jumps and
maybe it becomes easier to think about
certain kinds of things because kind of
the jump distance is smaller or maybe
maybe there are more things that we can
sort of see in the world in the natural
world that we would be able to say oh I
immediately know what that is because
it's part of our kind of concept space
that we're able to have in a in a bigger
brain but you know for example the
very fact that we have the idea of
language with its sort of compositional
structure and sub phrases and things
like this is that a consequence of the
size of our brains is it different from
what your average cat or dog would have
just because their brains are smaller is
there some threshold that we pass where
we're able to have these sort of
compositional languages um and which
have been pretty important for the
progress of our civilization and is
there some other threshold we'd reach
where something else happens that maybe
we haven't yet imagined that is sort of
the the uh the next level of sort of
intelligence capability I'm not sure I I
tend to think that
it's like Universal computation that
once you get above a certain threshold
you're there you're finished that's what
the principle of computational
equivalence that I developed back in 30
years ago or something now kind of
suggests it doesn't talk about it talks
about the overall computational
capability of a system it doesn't really
address things that are more detailed
about kind of the structure of meaning
space and so on really the question of
what is what happens when you compute
things is different from what happens
when you say I think that's a meaningful
concept and so on this idea of sort of
breaking the world into Concepts that we
can kind of stuffen our brains is a
separate thing from asking sort of what
does it take to compute what happens in
the world and I think the um uh this
question of of sort of you know what
happens is that are there other
thresholds in kind of the way that we
handle Concepts and concept space and
the idea of meaning and so on um I I I'm
a bit skeptical I think perhaps not
Perhaps it is more like Universal
computation where we get to a certain
level and then we're done but it's not
obvious and it's certainly an
interesting thing to imagine what would
happen you know what what happens if our
brains are are sufficiently smaller than
than they are and we only can have
10,000 words in our languages rather
than
50,000 uh it probably doesn't make much
difference what if you scale it down to
only 100 words that's less than even the
smallest constructed languages have and
by the way even in languages you know
constructed languages with 200 words in
them there's a lot of nuance that you
cannot communicate there's a a kind of a
a bulk this is what I'm basically
talking about that you can say but when
it comes to the finer details you can't
express those and arguably that's the
cat and dog situation as well but the
kind of the global I'm happy I'm not
happy type story is expressable in cat
and dog language but the detailed kind
of philosophical discussion is notable
in cat and dog language and so I suppose
the question then arises okay if you
scale up the number of words and you can
have sort of a more detailed discussion
about things what does that what does
that do for one I suppose I suppose one
example of a um a place where we get to
see this a little bit is when you get
specialized in some field there's all
this jargon you start using and that
jargon is different from the everyday
language so I don't know if you're in
the medical field or something like this
you'll you'll start talking with all
this jargon which does give you a in a
sense a finer set of gradations about
what you're talking about than the
common language does and so I suppose
that that's that's um perhaps a a way to
imagine what it would be like to have a
uh to be dealing with just vastly more
words in one's everyday language
is that one gets to make these finer
gradations these more more detailed
kinds of uh uh discussions I in a sense
one can think of this as what level when
we think of human language it is a kind
of formalization of the world we get to
say you know table and by that we mean a
large class of things with four legs or
have many legs that have flat surfaces
and things like that we don't have to go
into all those details or pointed
particular thing we can more abstractly
just say the word table it's packaged
that concept together and I suppose the
the question then is as we package more
Concepts we get
to well it's sort of an interesting
issue what uh in in some sense it gives
us a bigger construction kit for
figuring out both how to talk about the
world and how to make things in the
world or explain the world and so on and
I suppose in a sense as we built our
computational language our wol language
system for instance you know that's
again what we're doing there is to
identify these kind of lumps of
computational work that represent uh
kind of the um uh uh these kind kind of
computational Concepts that are worth us
kind of identifying and implementing
actually it's an interesting question
there we're at the point where we have
about 7,000 built-in functions in wol
language that cover a very wide range of
areas and it's an interesting issue at
what point it stops being learnable at
what point the number of functions is
just too big that one can readily have
one's arms around sort of everything
that's there I think this is the big
difference between natural language and
computational language is that in
computational language one has a
designer who is trying to sort of keep
things sort of organized in a principled
way so that by learning the principle
one learn learns a big swath of of
actual functionality and of course in in
wol language we're leveraging the
meaning of things in English where we're
using English words to express things so
you don't have to kind of learn
everything from scratch but I think
that's again you know with brains of the
size we have so to speak there's a
certain amount you can learn and a
certain amount you can kind of maintain
in your brain and then beyond that um
it's uh uh it's something where you're
going to have to look it up every time
type thing and you've got to remember
only sort of the higher level fact I
mean in general the sort of the story of
of lots of kind of modern education
would be that you know learn those
higher level abstract things because
that's what we've reached so far in the
progress of our civilization you only
have to learn all the specific details
when they have not been abstracted to
something more General and that's the
the you might argue that you know you
have a bigger brain you have to abstract
ra less and and perhaps in a sense the
um uh and and by abstracting less you
get to make less General statements you
get to have less connections and
analogies between different areas so
okay so that would be a that would be a
downer for having the very big brain the
big brain where you have a million words
in your language maybe you never have to
abstract anything maybe you can always
take each case as it is you can say oh
yes there are there are beavers and
there are Odo and there are moles and
there are this and that and the other
everything has a separate word we never
have to aggregate these together and say
wait a minute they're all mammals let's
say um we never have to do that
aggregation we can always just do it
Case by case I suppose it's the analogy
between what happens if you're doing
mathematics with things like automated
theorem proving where you have a
computer just grinding out sort of from
detailed axioms of a mathematical system
you're grinding out kind of the
mathematical results without a broader
understanding that's something that you
can get away with if you are a computer
for example or if you are a brain that
is big enough to store a million you
know to deal with millions of words you
can get away with just saying oh there's
this particular mathematical theorem and
this one and this one and this one and
this one and this one and you never have
to pull them together to uh to make a
more General kind of theory so I was
actually sort of an interesting point of
view that uh uh the bigger the brain the
less you actually have to abstract the
less you have to make General statements
um and that um that's sort of a a a
thing one might say about AI as well um
you know in a sense if you've got a
small AI if you've got some small
neuronet if it's going to make
conclusions about lots of different
kinds of systems it has to have a a
model that kind of compresses the
information about all those systems into
something that will fit in that kind of
AI brain but on the other hand if it's a
giant AI brain that has you know you
know quadrillions of different
Connections in it and so on then it
could just say hey I'm going to take uh
you know I'm going to take this thing
that I saw over here and that thing that
I saw over there I never have to kind of
compress them into a model I can always
just take them Case by case and just say
wait a minute I saw that before you know
100 years ago I saw that thing happen
let me just uh make use of that thing
that I saw happen before I'm just going
to say it's going to happen again now
rather than having to kind of aggregate
together and make something that is a
sort of a smaller uh that's a that's a
true model for what's going on that that
says you know imagine that you were
dropping sort of cannonballs off the
Leaning Tower of Pisa back in the day as
Galileo did um and imagine that you were
also dropping I don't know uh pieces of
um P rocks from um uh the um what is
that place called The the big tower in
Venice um uh you know you imagine you
you're dropping rocks from one
cannonballs from the other etc etc etc
and you could just say I just remember
what happens with the cannonball in this
place what happens with The Rock in that
place I've got so much memory I can just
store all of those things um whereas
what actually happened
was the science of mechanics got
developed so that one could with one
model would just say hey doesn't matter
if it's a cannonball or Rock if it's
this tower that Tower there's just a
kind of a a model that compresses all
that information so that you can say
what's going to happen in all these
different cases so in a sense that's the
that's what you are forced to do if you
have a more limited brain so to speak uh
and uh uh and so so it's maybe the
tradeoffs become um uh just become
slightly
different let's
see well all right I asked for general
questions here so I get one from Lola
here how would you begin an introduction
to a chemistry
course um you know I have to say I'm
always embarrassed that chemistry is a
field that I never really learned as a
kid and um I to tell a a story about
myself and in England where I grew up
you know there are these standardized
exams you have to do at various times
and I think there was one that I did
when I was like 14 years old about
chemistry and I really had not learned
much at all about chemistry and I you
know night before I'm kind of learning
all the stuff for this for this exam and
I did just fine in the exam um I think I
have a decent memory so it's kind of an
easy an easy thing from that point of
view but I I used to say that
essentially all the chemistry I knew I
learned the night before that exam
that's no longer quite true because as
we built out chemistry functionality
more from language and as I've made use
of chemistry in lots of different places
um it's uh I have learned more about it
but if you ask me kind of typical high
school chemistry of what what happens
when you mix this white powder with that
white powder and and put it in with this
acid and so on and so on and so on I
typically will not know the answer to
those things I would typically say Hey
you know wolf malfa does a really good
job
uh answering sort of uh school chemistry
questions ask it because I don't know
but what would I say in in sort of
introducing the idea of chemistry I
think the the first thing to say
is
that when we first first thing to know
is sort of all matter is made up
ultimately of
atoms and there are about a 100 kinds of
atoms hydrogen helium lithium brillium
Boron Etc the periodic table is the
inventory of all the kinds of atoms that
exist in in the world uh it's uh okay
footnote to that you know we don't the
as we go far out we get you know
past U 92 the 92nd one of these they're
all so far as we know unstable they're
all self these atoms all self-destruct
in progressively mostly progressively
shorter amounts of time we don't
absolutely know that there isn't another
one out there that's stable that could
be made in the right kind of explosion
of a star or something like that but for
most purposes most of chemistry concerns
itself with maybe 20 different kinds of
atoms with sort of Trace contributions
from different obscure kinds and uh the
um in a sense the story of chemistry is
a story of given these limited set of
building blocks of you know uh carbon
and hydrogen and oxygen and nitrogen and
so on uh given these limited set of
atomic building blocks what what can you
make with those how do those things
stick together to make molecules what
kinds of molecules can you make then
what are the properties of those
molecules those properties might be what
happens when one molecule runs into
another molecule does it react to uh to
rearrange the atoms and to produce other
molecules does it just bounce off does
it not pay attention to the other
molecule that's one set of things
another set of things are what are in a
sense the physical properties of those
molecules if you shine light on them
what happens to them if you uh put them
in shine radio waves on them what
happens to them those kinds of things if
you put these molecules together and
this isn't really chemistry so much
anymore you put these molecules together
do they make a solid what are the
properties of that solid
they make a gas what are the properties
of that gas and so on but so one
question is you've got these limited set
of building blocks actually carbon and
hydrogen or even just Carbon on its own
is is a sufficient building block to
make all kinds of things and so what
one's thinking about doing is taking for
example carbon atoms and putting them
together and one feature of atoms atoms
are um uh you know an an individual atom
the different kinds of atoms are
slightly different sizes but they're
more or less the same size they're all
about a little bit less than a billionth
of a meter across um the uh uh and these
so one question is what what clumps of
molecules will actually stick together
and there are particular
Arrangements that successfully stick
together and others that do not so for
example water H2O two hydrogen's one
oxygen that's a particular configuration
of of atoms that sticks together to make
molecules sometimes you can have things
which you can think of as a little bit
like you know a
well the the one question is of how do
the atoms stick together to make
molecules there are sort of two
fundamental ways that happens that
so-called calent bonding and ionic
bonding uh one ionic bonding
is what happens when when well again
we're getting into more detail here but
when the the when there electric charges
basically uh that are causing one atom
to attract another atom um and that's
what happens I don't know table salt
sodium chloride is an example of uh of
something which is where the the atoms
are ionically stuck together but
actually those atoms where you can have
a sodium and a chlorine together and
they're kind of like a molecule but
really when it's in solid form that
thing arranges itself in a giant crystal
where you've got sodiums and chlorines
and they're arranged in a certain in an
array and that's kind of like one giant
molecule in some sense held together by
these electrical forces when you have
something like water the the more what
what's happening there is the thing is
being held together by the following
fact So within each atom there's a
nucleus with protons and neutrons and
there's then sort of very big outside of
the nucleus very it's big and puffy the
nucleus is very tiny relative to this
there are electrons and each kind of
atom has a certain number of electrons
and what happens is when you put atoms
near each other what happens is that the
electrons between the different atoms
are kind of shared between different
atoms and that process of sharing
electrons between different atoms is
what leads to the the fact that the
atoms are sort of held together you
can't pull them apart because these
electrons are kind of yes I'm being
shared between between these two
different atoms and the way that that
sharing Works depends in detail on what
the arrangement of electrons is in each
particular kind of atom and so in
particular the
um uh the well one of the one of the key
facts about electrons is that when you
are if you try to put electrons in a box
for example you'll find that the
electrons they they'll the first
electrons you put in the Box can have
very low energy they're just sitting
there as you try and put more electrons
in you the electrons will never be
prepared to be in sort of in the same
place in the same energy as the ones
that were already there they have this
idea of the Exclusion Principle which
says that two electrons can't be sort of
in the same energy level in the same
place at the same time and so that means
that if you want to put more electrons
in this box they have to have
progressively higher energies and that
box could be an atom and what happens is
that there are these uh essentially
these electrons that in order to put
another electron into that atom it is
forced to be in a higher energy than the
electrons that are already there and
what ends up happening is that the the
it's again a little complicated but the
um uh roughly what does it mean for the
electrons to be sort of in the same
place at the same time well uh you can
kind of think of the electrons as
um a bad picture is the electrons sort
of orbiting around the nucleus that's
not a very good picture because nothing
is moving through time like that it's
rather that there's kind of an
arrangement of electrons that uh is as
if it has I'm trying to think how to
explain this the the official terms are
uh orbital angular momentum um but I
think that's a very confusing term
because that originally arose because
the mathematics of thinking about kind
of electrons in an atom was similar to
the mathematics of thinking about you
know planets and a solar system at least
that's the base of it um and so that has
Concepts like anim momentum of of
planets going around stars and so on and
that's not um it's it's not quite the
same type of very mechanical motion that
you see
but what ends up happening is that in
there are these different angular
momentum States and the as you get to a
higher angular momentum State there are
kind of of more different directions in
which the electrons can be stuffed in
and so that leads one to have these
different Arrangements of electrons
where for example in a hydrogen atom
where there's just one electron the it
can just sit there helium atom two
electrons okay so it turns out electrons
have this notion of spin um and uh the
one electron can mean that one ener
energy level in hydrogen as you go to
helium you got two electrons and where
do they go well turns out have the spin
that can be either up or down
effectively and the two electrons in
helium one is an an up spin electron the
other's a down spin electron they can
kind of hang out in the same state by
the time you get to lithium you've
you've filled up this first shell as
it's called of the kind of lowest energy
configuration of uh lowest energy sort
of place to put the electrons and you
have to put another electron out sort of
uh out away from that in in a shell and
it's kind of hanging out on its own and
that's what happens in lithium which has
three electrons um let's see hydrogen
helium lithium burum Boron so burum has
four um and uh that can then get paired
up that NE electron can get paired up
this the the next Shell of electrons has
can uh can have uh a total of let's see
2 L + one so that's some uh uh three um
possible electrons in it so what roughly
happens is that these electrons are kind
of in these atoms because of the
Exclusion Principle they're kind of
they're forced to sort of pro they fill
up these shells and then once the shell
is filled up more electrons can't be in
that shell they have to be sort of
outside of that and so what roughly
happens is that atoms where there are
some electrons that are just sort of
hanging out outside in the
um not sort of well integrated into a
shell those tend to be more reactive
atoms they have more those sort of out
outlying electrons have more tendency to
be able to kind of uh sort of interact
with and get and get exchanged and
shared with uh other atoms and so for
example if you look at the periodic
table the idea of that is it's arranged
so that um the atoms that the elements
that um uh correspond
to that have sort of the same rough
configuration of sort of spare electrons
are arranged in the same vertical column
and so for example on the right hand
side of the periodic table are the noble
gases which correspond to atoms where
the shells are all filled up where
there's sort of no separate electrons
hanging out and those uh those things
helium
neon argon Krypton Xenon um these are
all they all exist as gases and they are
they have the feature that they don't
interact much with anything because they
just don't have these extra sort of
outter electrons that can be exchanged
with other atoms and so on they just
tend to hang out and and sort of uh um
be on their own so to
speak but I think the the next question
is okay so there are these atoms and
they have these electrons and the
electrons can sort of there can be a
certain number of electrons that are uh
sort of available to exchange with other
things and that leads to this idea of
veilance of sort of how many other atoms
are you do you want to be connected to
so for example carbon has veilance of
four it kind of any carbon atom likes to
be kind of connected it likes to have
bonds which are essentially shared
electrons
with with four other atoms so now the
question is now it becomes a question of
well what's the you know you've got
carbon that has sort of four bonds for
each atom how do you arrange what are
the possible Arrangements of carbon
atoms given that each carbon atom has
four bonds how can you sort of make this
construction kit of molecules made of
carbon atoms where each one has these
four bonds and so you can draw graphs
networks that say okay there's a carbon
atom here it's it's got these four bonds
it's connect each that's connected to
another carbon atom and to another
carbon atom and so on and you can kind
of make all these different shapes out
of carbon atoms and sometimes in in
typical
hydrocarbons very common kinds of
chemicals uh you'll have bunch of
carbons and then maybe the hydrogen
which has veence of one the the sort of
the bonds from the carbon will stick out
and they won't connect to another carbon
there'll just be a hydrogen hanging out
there um so then there's the sort of
combinatorial question um of uh um what
uh you know given that you have I don't
know 10 carbon atoms for example what
possible arrangements are there that you
can put these carbon atoms in the answer
is a lot the um the number of molecules
that you get
um uh oh my gosh what are they called
isomers isomers yeah the number of um uh
the number of possible Arrangements of
um a given number of for example carbon
atoms grows very rapidly with the number
of carbon atoms so one Arrangement might
be all the carbon atoms are just in a
line and there's a whole sequence of
hydrocarbon molecules that arejust these
linear chains with progressively more
carbon atoms another possibility is that
there can be something that's branched
where um uh the um uh where you'll have
the the backbone and then you'll have
one carbon atom instead of just having a
hydrogen on the side of another carbon
and you'll make this branched molecule
and so on so the thing in a sense the
story of chemistry can be thought of at
least this part of chemistry um the
story uh and this is when it comes to
things that involve carbon and hydrogen
and oxygen and so on that's the story of
organic chemistry um when you're dealing
with more with things like
metal atoms and things like this you end
up in and other kinds of other kinds of
um atoms that's inorganic uh chemistry
organic chemistry is really this big
story of all these different sort of
Arrangements you can make with this
fairly limited set of possible atoms and
so how many are there well there are big
catalogs chemical abstracts a big
catalog of these things there maybe a
100 million uh types of Arrangements of
of atoms into molecules that people have
cataloged so far and somebody found a
use for it sometime now the number that
could in principle exist is infinite you
can just keep on tacking carbon atoms on
make bigger and biger molecules
sometimes the the just saying oh you can
stick four carbons out onto each carbon
um it doesn't work out because for
example let's say you try and make a
tree where you're just having more and
more and more carbon stuck on in this
tree eventually there'll be so many
carbons there they just wouldn't fit
they'll they'll they won't um they
because the carbon atoms have a certain
size you just won't be able to fit them
in so there are constraints like that
but in in a first approximation you're
just making up these different possible
graphs of networks of of how the carbon
atoms are connected together with the
constraint of the veence of the of the
carbon atoms and so on so that's kind of
you construct these molecules another
question is well what shape are these
molecules it turns out you can get a
decent approximation to that just by
thinking about about these bonds that
are these sort of shared electron pieces
as like Springs and you can just think
of the thing as kind of it's got some
some sort of repulsion between atoms and
they're pulled together with springs
it's very similar to the way that one
typically lays out graphs when one's
just trying to visualize a graph that
same general type of approach gives one
some rough idea of what molecules look
like and one can be more precise if one
has the more detailed kind of
interaction potentials the more detailed
Force laws between different atoms one
can make a more more more accurate view
of what for example the threedimensional
structure of a particular molecule will
be and for small molecules that are just
made from a bunch of carbon and hydrogen
so on one can get pretty good idea of
what the what the molecule will look
like when it gets to much bigger
molecules things like proteins that one
that might have millions of atoms in
them um and which have it gets much more
difficult to know how this molecule will
fold up and it's been a long-term kind
of comp complicated issue how that works
and that's the the shapes of proteins
are really important for how they how
they actually operate biologically and
that's been sort of the protein folding
problem has been a long-term problem
that there's been a fair bit of progress
on using AI methods in recent times um
maybe not quite as much progress as some
people might hope for but but one can
get a much better idea of how the
molecule actually arranges itself sort
of based on sort of examples of how
maybe 100,000 different molecules where
we know how they arranged themselves
work you can kind of extrapolate from
that to to other types of molecules but
so in a first approximation that's
that's what happens now when you if you
really want to say in tremendous detail
how the molecules how the atoms uh
arrange themselves together to make a
molecule that's pretty hard to figure
out the first approximation of kind of
this you know spring like force flws and
and so on that's pretty easy and one can
do that for pretty big molecules but to
do it really precisely using the
equations of quantum mechanics and
things like this that's something which
maybe for a hundred atoms you can do
maybe a little bit more than that now um
but that's really hard to figure out to
do the quantum chemistry of figuring out
exactly how the atoms are arranged in a
molecule is pretty hard um but
uh okay so that's so so the first step
is what molecules can you make the next
step is well what happens when you have
chemical reactions what is a chemical
reaction a chemical reaction is two
molecules in the end what it is is two
molecules crash into each other and
somehow they rearrange themselves and
what comes out is some number of other
molecules the molecules crash into each
other they sort of break apart the atoms
get rearranged into other molecules and
then the result is the products of the
of the chemical reaction and uh uh
sometimes and the Dynamics of how those
molecules come together is truly
complicated and it's poorly poorly
worked out even now the the question of
sort of what is possible as in which
molecules which atoms can come out given
that these atoms went in well the atoms
are you know if if you've got a sulfur
atom that came in there's a sulfur atom
that's going to go out and there's a lot
that can be figured out it was figured
out 150 years ago or so now of kind of
the the just tracing which atoms go in
which atoms come out that determines a
lot about what chemical reactions can
happen another thing that is important
is sometimes the molecules are very very
tightly bound into a molecule sorry the
atoms are very tightly bound into a
molecule and sometimes they're much more
Loosely Bound in if you take something
that's Loosely Bound in and you
rearrange it so that the so that it's
tightly Bound in there's energy that is
dissipated by that proc process there's
the if you're taking something where
you've just sort of the thing is
bouncing around and so on and then you
kind of lock it in place you're
dissipating some energy in doing that
and and so that that determines whether
when when the chemical reaction happens
when the molecules get rearranged does
it produce heat does it release energy
that will cause the the and the heat is
in the form of motion of of molecules so
it's it's it's releasing energy which
goes into making the molecules sort of
Wiggle around more or is it using up
energy to get the molecules do you have
to Ram the molecules together with lots
of energy to get them to possibly stick
maybe the molecules tend to repel each
other and you just have to you have to
Ram them together really hard to get
them to uh to stick and so that leads to
things like endothermic reactions and
exothermic reactions endothermic
reactions ones where they they're going
to take energy to make the reaction
happen exothermic once the reaction
happens it's going to release a bunch of
energy and and that's that's kind of the
um the next story of sort of how uh the
next sort of level of thinking about
chemistry is being able to figure out
okay what is the sort of energy budget
of of what's going to happen now another
piece that's kind of complicated is has
to do with um uh
what
has to do with okay uh it it's sort of a
counting thing and it ultimately has to
do with this idea of entropy which we
can talk about at Great length um and
it's it's to do with well if this
reaction is going to happen and happens
at some rate uh how many different how
many different ways are there for it to
happen how many different molecules are
there available to make it happen there
lots of trade-offs and in the end you
get these mathematical formulas that
tell you things about the rate of
chemical reactions and so on and whether
certain chemical reactions can happen or
not whether there whether there's enough
atoms enough molecules there to make
this reaction happen whether that
overcomes the whe okay so a typical
issue is this typical issue is when you
have molecules bouncing around in a
partic in a material in a gas in a
liquid something like this you uh and by
the way I should say that in chemistry
liquids are
the place where it's easiest to get
chemical reactions to happen in a gas
the molecules are all bouncing around
but there just aren't so many molecules
so the chance of two molecules hitting
is considerably smaller in a solid the
molecules are locked in place and so
they don't get a chance to go visit
other molecules in liquid the molecules
are all sort of bouncing randomly around
but there's a high density of molecules
and uh and so so it's possible for
chemical reactions to happen and that's
why you know if you're going through I
don't know airport security or something
they're always concerned about what
volume of liquids do you have because
liquids are the things that you that can
be used to make chemical reactions that
can produce explosives or do other bad
things or whatever um and uh and so
liquids are liquids are sort of the The
Sweet Spot for chemical reactions to
happen so okay in um in a liquid there's
the question of of uh these molecules
are all bouncing around liquid is at
some temperature the temperature
characterizes the average energy of the
molecules but what's the actual
distribution of of speeds of molecules
in the liquid it's given by a thing
called the maximal boltzman distribution
and it is of the form uh well
mathematically it's v s e to the minus
v^ 2 um but it basically is a curve that
at zero speed it's zero and very high
speeds at zero and it kind of has a hump
in the middle and and the the tail of
the hump falls off
exponentially and so okay so why is why
is this relevant it's relevant because
if you have a chemical reaction that
requires a certain energy of the
molecules in order for it to happen that
you you have to have molecules with that
energy and if that energy is sort of
high compared to the hump in this
distribution only a small number of
molecules will have that high energy and
it's sort of this trade-off between the
exponentially decay of the number of
molecules with a certain energy and the
total number of molecules or the total
different Arrangements of molecules that
you can have and that tradeoff sort of a
trade-off between uh um that that
involves temperature which determines
the the the position of the hump the
average energy where the exponential
lies and the number of molecules and the
number of configurations of molecules uh
that that sort of tradeoff is a big
determinant of what chemical reactions
can happen and not
so uh yeah that's a very a very quick
and rough dis discussion of chemistry so
just to say a little bit more about it I
mean so you know a big piece of
chemistry is okay the goal of some piece
of chemistry will be make a particular
kind of molecule because it's useful for
something or another and the question is
you've got raw material you've got
molecules you can just get out of
seawater or molecules that you can get
from a rock or something like this how
do you rearrange those molecules to turn
them into thing you want well what you
have to do is figure out a series of
chemical reactions um that uh uh that
will take you from the the original
ingredients you have to the thing you
want and there's a huge art of synthetic
chemistry that involves oh you do this
reaction then that reaction then that
reaction and and the biggest syntheses
these days are maybe 30 steps long so
you're doing 30 steps of do this then
that then that then that then that to
make this particular molecule that is
the thing you're eventually going to
want actually interesting question is in
biology where these things work a bit
differently uh using bigger molecules
protein molecules things like that I
actually don't know what the longest
synthesis pathways are um but uh in in
sort of chemistry that is done on an
industrial scale for example it's
usually it's usually maybe tens 10 steps
you know and the and the the sort of the
state-ofthe-art might be 30 steps and
and what are those steps well there's
sort of an inventory of reactions you
know if you learn organic chemistry
which I have to admit I have not so the
you know you learn all these particular
named reactions and so on a um this name
that name the other reaction in fact the
these reactions are often called name
reactions because they're they're named
reactions and you say I'm going to do a
this then a that then a that then a that
and how do you actually get those
reactions to happen well you put in some
reagent some particular chemical that is
the thing you need to make this reaction
happen you heat things up to a certain
temperature you do this you do that that
that's that's really you don't have a
lot of control actually you just get to
put reagents in you put to get to put
have a certain temperature those are the
main controls you have and then that
particular reaction will happen you let
it run for a while and then all the
molecules that are going to attach in
this way or that way have attached then
you go on you do the next thing and so
on and and there's a big art to to being
able to sort of put these steps together
to get to the thing you want and
sometimes you know there are things like
you'll put on a protecting group that
will uh sort of arrange that the
particular place you were going to that
one reaction that one molecule that
comes in oh it can't get to this place
where it would otherwise attach because
there's a protecting group there and you
keep going and then you do another
reaction that makes the protecting group
fall off later and and so on and that
that's that's a big piece to the the
story of what goes on there in synthetic
chemistry and kind of analytical
chemistry it's all sort of well I've got
this thing what is it you know how do I
tell what molecule I have here what can
I do with it for example you might uh
put in a mass spectrometer which which
uh will sort of crush will will will
sort of make the molecule disintegrate
into its constituent atoms and it can
count how many hydrogen atoms how many
sulfur atoms how many this how many that
were in that original molecule or you
might do something where you uh will um
look at the uh interaction of light or
radio energy radio waves with with a
molecule and so for example if you're
dealing with microwaves radio
um short wavelength radio waves um your
your um uh what what what ends up
happening is the the radio energy comes
in and it makes the atoms in the
molecule wiggle around and depending on
the exact shape of the molecule the
wiggling will be different and you can
detect that because when the molecule
Wiggles it it absorbs some uh it that
exactly which frequencies of radio
energy it absorbs determined by kind of
what modes of wiggling it can have so
for example if you were to have sort of
a molecule which just consisted of two
atoms on a spring there will be some
characteristic frequency where that
spring goes back and forth and at that
characteristic frequency radio energy
you put in will be absorbed by the
molecule because it'll just go into the
wiggling of the molecule and at other
frequencies the molecule will be like oh
that doesn't really help me it isn't the
frequency that I wiggle at so to speak
and so that's another type of analysis
one can do and and many things like
that let's see all right some other
questions related to this um how are
chemical reactions balanced to why is it
important to balance chemical reactions
well chemical reactions the balance of
chemical reactions just saying there's a
certain you know the molecules come in
that there a certain collection of atoms
in those molecules and those atoms will
be the the atoms that come out in in the
in the in the molecules that are
produced by the reaction now what gets
tricky is that sometimes in order to
balance the cono reaction you have to
say well we got to have two waters plus
one copper sulfate or something plus one
something else and that
matches uh sort of three nitrogen
molecules plus whatever plus whatever so
there's this kind of idea that that in
the end it's some number of of uh in the
end the number of atoms has to match of
each type has to match on the left hand
side and the right hand side but to
achieve that you may have to have
different numbers of molecules because
those are collections of atoms and what
you end up with is an equation that is a
so-called D Fantine equation an equation
involving integers that says okay for
every water molecule you've got two
hydrogens one oxygen for every carbon
dioxide molecule you've got one carbon
and two oxygens okay if we're going to
match up a methane or something um with
uh uh you know Carbon four hydrogens
with the carbon dioxide and the water
and so on how many methane and oxygen
for example with a carbon dioxide in the
water how many how many Waters plus how
many methanes do we need to match this
and that and that becomes an equation a
set of equ equation that you can write
out just in terms of how do we how do we
match up we've got to have an integer
number of water molecules an integer
number of of methane molecules how many
do we need so that we can match up the
atoms that are in them and it's not
really for for wol from language that is
a trivial uh sort of mathematical
problem it's for a human doing it it can
be quite tricky uh for the algorithms
that we have for solving interal
equations like that are big industrial
creatures that can grind through and do
that I mean in the you know foot note
there are equations of oing integers
that are arbitrarily difficult to solve
but they don't show up in chemistry the
ones in chemistry are are are
comparatively modest and are are
completely ground up by the industrial
methods of solving these kinds of
equations that one has now just because
the equation balances the the the
reaction balances so that the sort of
number of atoms matches up doesn't mean
the reaction will actually happen that's
a that's a question of uh of of whether
the the molecules the energies the mo
ules are such that you can get the
molecule you can Ram them together hard
enough that they'll actually interact or
whatever
else uh M rudo asks is it still right to
use the periodic table or is it a
feature of the past I think the periodic
table is still sort of as valid As It
Ever Was in its main elements so to
speak its main pieces this idea of sort
of veilance which is what determines
what column the the um uh the the atoms
are in that's that's still a fine thing
I'm not sure one can really do much
better than the periodic table as a way
to characterize sort of what reacts with
what now there are many many many
details that are not covered by the
periodic table it's just a very first
cut of what can react with what and
certainly in modern times you can
imagine a much more detailed sort of
fingerprint for every atom that can
determine you know can it really
interact with this and can it really
interact with that and certainly the
rules of thumb that say oh you know like
Xenon a noble gas just doesn't interact
with anything well except it does
because there's a molecule called Xenon
heop fluide Florine is such an
aggressive atom at interacting with
things that it can even interact with
Xenon to make that that kind of molecule
and um uh it's um so you know these
these kinds of rules of thumb don't
don't go all the way through uh but as a
first cut the periodic table I think is
a is remains a a pretty good kind of way
to know roughly what's going on now now
you know what happens in the periodic
table okay
so it's it's really a weirdly setup
thing because uh the I talked about
these electron shells and each
successive electron shell the um uh it
has um uh well the the the number of of
electrons that will go in it goes up
like if the shell is is
shell numbered L then it's 2 L + 1 * 2
is the number of electrons that will go
into it and that means that as you get
to higher shells you get more and more
um uh you get more and more electrons
per shell and you you can kind of fill
in more and more elements but more and
more types of atoms until you get ones
that have those sort of uh
uh until you get to the stage where you
have sort of all of them filled up and
you've got this non-reactive atom again
and so that's why in the periodic table
at the top there's just hydrogen helium
sort of hanging out on their own and
then there start to be rows that have
more atoms in them and then more and
more and more and then you get down to
the later parts of the table you got
these pieces that don't quite fit in the
the lanthanides and actinides and so on
that have to be sort of fitted in as a
footnote and that's those are bigger
shells where there are lots of different
kind of atoms that all correspond to
things filling in the parts of those
shells that's kind of a messy thing and
I think if one were to go on further
down with per table the shells would get
even bigger and one would have sort of
an even Messier situation in terms of
laying them out in two Dimensions but
those uh you know those atoms aren't
stable so that's not something of
relevance to chemistry I mean chemistry
is really dealing with the properties of
molecules where the where what matters
is the sort of configuration of
electrons in the molecules Nuclear
Physics is what deals with what when
what matters is the configuration of
neutrons and protons inside the
nuclei let's
see
uh AR asks is there research on
Computing outside classical Quantum
state of electrons example biology
chemical light based data storage and
processing
um well yes there's there's okay so if a
standard computer one is storing
information by the presence or absence
of electrons in little uh sort of
essentially traps that have been created
for them in the structure of the of the
Silicon semiconductor that makes up our
memory chip so it's either their
electrons hanging out there thousand of
them 10,000 of them whatever it is for
each bit or there aren't and um in a
first approximation it's a little bit
more complicated in in detail but that's
roughly what's happening and so you can
ask the question
well you know are there other ways you
could store the information the answer
is absolutely yes are they practical yet
well no not really I mean you could for
example say well I'm going to have this
this molecule that has a cage in it and
that cage will either have an iron atom
in it or it won't you say well can you
really make a molecule that has a cage
for an iron atom that will fit only one
iron atom and nothing else well
absolutely yes that's how hemoglobin
works that's how the iron that gets used
in our red blood cells to bind the
oxygen that gets transported around our
body that's the way that works so you
can you can do these things where you
make molecules that have that can have
for example multiple states of the
molecule either there's an iron there or
there isn't or the molecule is in this
configuration or that configuration you
can do that that's not yet become a
practical way to actually store
information um except well biology uses
that but in a sense well not quite I
mean biology uses the fact that
uh in proteins for example or in or in
DNA you have these big uh sort of big
units of of pieces of molecule that can
be fitted together one after the other
after the other um in kind of a a
polymer a like something like plastic is
a polymer where you have a molecule that
is effectively a long chain of identical
units with hydrogens and carbons and
things in them in the case of biology
this long chain of of units something
like DNA is a long chain of units but
the units aren't necessarily identical
it's a heteropolymer in the sense that
it can have these four different kinds
of units and each one of those units can
be added in so you can have a DNA
molecule that has you know atg c g t a
whatever with different sequences of
units all possible sequences of units
are allowed they are all it's possible
for the molecule to stick together with
all those different possible possible
sequences of units and that's a way to
store information because the the
particular configuration of units
determines whether you're storing a one
or a zero or whatever else and that's
another thing people have experimented
with is DNA storage of information it's
still more of a toy at this point for
when it comes to sort of digital
information that we store in things like
computers then it is um uh something
practical but it's of course the storage
mechanism that used by
biology in the case of a protein again
we've got these identical units amino
acids in that case about 20 of them that
are the possible units that get strung
together one after the other to make a
protein and we might have you know
10,000 of these in a big protein and um
uh the um it's in that case a little bit
trickier because while the sort of
backbone of the protein allows any
possible sequence the protein then folds
up
and not all sequences will allow the
protein to consistently fold etc etc
etc
um Jimmy comments molecules are graphs
system is balancing molecules and
equations is just a a new variation of
of things like are two graphs equivalent
yeah that's absolutely that's absolutely
true I mean the you can think of
chemical reactions as being examples of
rewriting and we've even done some
experiments with that because graph
rewriting is the underlying stuff that
shows up in our physics project and
there's sort of what's the analogy
between what happens there and what
happens in chemistry and one can make
some of those analogies and it's quite
quite fun to do
that uh okay so wingley asks what
strategies and techniques can be applied
to effectively control and optimize
chemical reactions for practical
applications including maximized yield
maximizing yield minimizing weight Wast
achieving desired products so in a first
approximation you've got a liquid you've
got a gas the molecules just sort of
randomly bouncing around one molecule
hits another etc etc etc big idea is the
idea of
catalysts so a catalyst is something
which often in in the case of industrial
chemistry there'll be some solid surface
some metal um uh some and the metal the
surface of that metal has all kinds of
shapes on it and what happens is that
the molecules in the gas or the liquid
they'll get stuck in one of those shapes
and that that when they stick in that in
that shape the molecule will be stuck so
that one end of the molecule is sticking
up or whatever else and that will cause
that to be much easier for the other
molecules it it kind of locks the
molecule in place so that the molecules
that might be going to interact with it
uh will always be able to hit it in the
right way they won't kind of bounce off
some other part of the molecule that was
irrelevant to the reaction so catalysts
are a way where you can basically
organize the molecules in in
geometrically organize the molecules so
that they are optimized to be to be to
interact with each other and that's
something people discovered catalysts
well in in famous industrial processes
130 years ago or more uh it's like oh
you can use a silver Catalyst or
something for this you can use a
platinum Catalyst for this you can use
this thing as a catalyst that thing as a
catalyst um that's a um uh and typically
those are solid surfaces that can
geometrically organize molecules now in
biology there are enzymes which are
types of proteins which have the feature
that they will hold other proteins or
other molecules in just the right
configuration to be able to have a
reaction be more likely to happen and
the effect is a big effect like it is in
biology it's not uncommon for reaction
to be a billion times more likely when
it is mediated by an enzyme effectively
a catalyst that can kind of hold things
in the right configuration they
not now I mean in terms of other ways to
control reactions there are other some
other things you can do I mean roughly
you heat things up you cool things down
you squirt chemicals in you don't squirt
chemicals in that's the first
approximation then there are catalysts
then there are things like light um so
for example there are reactions where if
you shine ultraviolet light on the thing
then a reaction will happen and it won't
otherwise so for example modern modern
dentistry there are plenty of of things
where there's some particular kind of
glue let's say where the thing will sort
of form into a polymer if there's if
there's ultraviolet light and won't
otherwise um and and other places where
the ultraviolet light is enough to kind
of Kick the the atoms to the the
molecules so that they can arrange
themselves in a particular way and they
wouldn't otherwise so that's another
type of control one has over over
chemical reactions it' be really great
if there was more microscopic control if
it was possible I mean in in biological
systems there is this very elaborate
control mechanism with all these
different shapes of molecules all
arranging themselves and and
geometrically configuring themselves in
the right way we don't have any way to
do that in sort of industrial chemistry
other than with things like catalysts
and so on it would be very interesting
if there was sort of a more uh sort of
um you know
um uh nanoscale way of doing that if
there was some uh uh kind of um
um sort of a a way of of getting
molecules to sort of organize themselves
um in you know if you could get
molecules that were sort of special
little machine likee molecules um um and
this is kind of the idea of molecular
scale manufacturing you've got a
molecule that acts like a machine most
molecules they just sit there maybe they
twist around a little bit but they they
really other than having chemical
reactions they don't they don't they
they can't sort of do much they're just
uh uh they um uh but but imagine you
could have a molecule that had a whole
was was a whole machine where if you
just Shine the right light on it or the
right kind of radio energy on it the
molecule will say oh yeah that's a
that's a a piece of programming I'm
going to now take that piece of
programming and I'm going to rearrange
myself and I'm going to make myself have
this particular opening that will have
particular where the particular other
molecule will stick in that's been a a
kind of a dream since the since the
1980s actually to do molecular scale man
manufacturing to make a nanot technology
that can be operated where where you can
kind of make these nanom machines
uh chemistry is a very coarse version of
that chemistry it's really heated up you
put the reagents in maybe you have a
catalyst but that's as far as you go the
idea that you could actually have a
programmable nanom machine that would be
down at the molecular scale actually
sort of determining by its by
configuring itself what to do that will
be a wonderful thing people tried to do
this in the 1980s for a variety of
reasons they sort of gave up um I think
they gave up too early and I'm hoping
that that will be a thing that comes
back and that it won't be the case that
biological life you know is the only
place where it's been discovered how to
do that you know biological life has
this huge stack of different mechanisms
and all these complicated molecules and
Pathways and all this kind of thing the
essence of what's needed for nanom
machines is surely much simpler than
that we just don't know how to make one
but once we have made one nanom machine
we're in pretty good shape for making
other ones because our one nanom machine
we we put it to work to make other Nano
machines and it it uh it will do a good
job of that um you know people had
worried in the 198s that maybe we make
these nanom machines and they just work
too well and everything in the world
gets turned into gray goo because
everything gets turned into just a copy
of the nanom machine I think that's an
that's probably an extreme concern um
but uh it's that's but the first step is
can we make an Nano machine at all and
that's something which you know that's
the future of of kind of of chemistry is
sort of truly programmable chemistry
where it's programmable the molecular
scale and in a sense there's a there's
something sort of in between there of
Material Science where you're making
materials let's say particularly solids
that have not just a crystal lattice
where the crystal just has pieces of of
uh of of you know atoms arranged in a
particular very regular array but let's
say some more complicated arrangement of
of of atoms that's sort of an
intermediate step
there well let's
see
uh wingley is asking about molecular
level mechanisms governing the magnetic
properties of
materials
so the big fact about magnetism is every
electron is like a tiny magnet it's like
a tiny bar magnet with a North Pole and
a South Pole every single electron and
electrons can be arranged in different
configurations in different um uh in in
in atoms and what happens in something
like iron is it has uh couple of
electrons I guess which is that right is
it one is it two I'm not sure anyway it
has electrons that the real question is
when electrons are um uh like bar
magnets if you take a bunch of bar
magnets they will like
to uh arrange themselves to be to be
parallel um the uh and so if you if if
these little electrons they you know
which can be have be like bar magnets
were oriented in different ways if you
get them close enough to each other
they'll have a habit of all the line
lining themselves up and some materials
iron Cobalt nickel are are three common
ones have the property that in the
crystals that are made from putting
together atoms of those of those
elements the electrons are sort of close
enough together that their magnetic
effects kind of add up and so what tends
to happen is you get this phenomenon of
ferromagnetism where you get where all
the electrons can be lined up all have
their spins lined up all have their bar
magnets lined up and that means that
even though each individual electron has
is like a very very very tiny bar
magnets all those electrons together are
like a big bar magnet and so you can
actually get for example a a a bar
magnet made of iron that is this whole
uh configuration this whole that has all
these electrons where they're all lined
up if you heat it up the electrons will
lose their their they'll they'll be sort
of kicked around enough that they won't
that the the forces that cause them to
line up will be overwhelmed by the by
the sort of energy of them just bouncing
around that's the so-called cury
temperature at which iron loses its
magnetism but um the
uh
other uh really what the these different
kinds of paramagnetism diamagnetism and
so on they're all uh different effects
that when you when you have a magnetic
field it will tend to the magnetic field
goes in certain direction the the all
the little magnets will tend to line up
along the magnetic field line
along the direction of the magnetic
field and in the case of
ferromagnetism um they'll line up and
they'll stay lined up because there just
all these molecules are all together in
the case of of diamagnetism they'll tend
to tend to uh kind of um sort of Kick
Back Against the magnetic field
paramagnetism is they they'll sort of be
locally aligned but they won't sort of
globally align and so different
materials have these different
characteristics
uh the the uh the the the things that
are sort of the most common um magnetic
materials Cobalt iron nickel um but then
there are ones which actually are
stronger magnets um gadolinium is one of
them it's a so-called Rare Earth magnet
that's a different part of the periodic
table it has a different arrangement of
electrons I actually don't remember
exactly what it is um but its crystals
are such that when when it makes when
you make it into a metal which is in
which all the mole all the atoms are
arranged in this very regular way um you
um you end up with um with something
that
um has uh uh much stronger magnetism
even than than iron all right I think I
should probably wrap up there um
anything else let's
see
uh are questions about chemistry I'm
just looking for here
um a question here from wingley about
what about radioactive substance
reactions yeah
well usually radioactivity is associated
with things that happen in the
nucleus and for example the nucleus
falling apart the neutrons in a nucleus
emitting high energy electrons turning
into protons uh things like this uh the
energy associated with nuclear processes
are vastly higher 10,000 times higher
than the energies associated with uh uh
with chemical processes so chemistry is
all about the electrons being exchanged
and all this kind of thing Nuclear
Physics is all about kind of much bigger
much higher energy things happening
around the nucleus so it's actually
pretty rare even when so so in one form
of nuclear Decay you get well you for
example get electrons emitted or you can
get alpha particles which are helium
nuclei Pro two protons two neutrons
emitted um the uh uh those things rarely
interact chemically because they usually
they're like zap you know they're
zipping out of there with very high
energy they never get to sort of
interact with the electrons and get sort
of pulled back by that so usually the um
uh the kind of the story of um um the
story radi activity is sort of a
separate story from the story of
chemistry now there's a whole field of
nuclear chemistry that has to do with uh
chemical processes that relate to things
that are radioactive and so on and that
for example uh I mean usually another
thing to say is that usually in
chemistry it doesn't really
matter the the the nucleus has a certain
number of protons that determines the
number of electrons that are typically
in that kind of atom the nucleus also
can have different numbers of neutrons
those are the different isotopes of
different elements usually in chemistry
it doesn't matter what isotope you have
it matters very little uh even in the
case of water case of hydrogen where you
know you normally hydrogen is just a
proton in the nucleus sometimes it's a a
proton and neutron that's duum proton or
two neutrons that's tritium um the the
rates chemical reactions happening with
dyum and happening with ordinary water
uh heavy water which has a duum and uh
duter
instead of ordinary hydrogen um the
rates of chemical reactions not that
different even in that case and for for
heavier elements the effect is even
smaller so it tends not to it on
geological time scales there can be
effects from these things but but in
typical kind of lab settings it doesn't
really make any
difference
um all right well that was a a short um
I'm sure I forgot a lot of um
um what
um
[Music]
um of what there is to say about
chemistry I think the original question
was how how would I begin an
introductory chemistry course and I
think the thing that I really didn't
understand when I was learning chemistry
is people would just tell me oh there's
this particular chemical and you have to
learn what it does and this and that and
the other and as I said I didn't do good
job didn't you know learn that stuff um
and I just found it really boring
because it was just like well a famous
quote by a physicist named Ernest R
Rutherford uh used to say you know
science is divided into two parts
physics and stamp collecting by which he
meant that chemistry just seemed like
this collection of just random facts oh
there's this particular molecule and it
does this oh there's this molecule that
does that whereas physics seemed more
systematic I person I think that that is
actually a reflection of in a sense the
greater computational sophistication of
chemistry in a sense it's like chemistry
is lots of little little computational
problems of can this molecule fit with
that molecule can this graph be written
this Rewritten this way and so on and
the fact that those are sort of
different computational problems there
is this phenomenon of computational
irreducibility that I talk about a lot
uh that um that kind of forces one that
there aren't just there isn't just a
global answer to all those little
computation problems uh the in general
with computational problems it's kind of
like you have to do the problem each
problem in turn to see what the answer
is and so in chemistry It's like because
it's much more in a sense computational
the it's it's kind of tying into this
idea that you have to just do the
computations and that's why the results
kind of seem random because there isn't
like the big fact that kind of brings
them all together it's like you have to
do each each computation separately so I
think the thing that would have helped
me a lot in understanding chemistry is
just the big picture of kind of
molecules are these possible
Arrangements of atoms I'm sure that's
said but it's not emphasized of you know
really you just think about it as you
take these things and you put sticks
together and you you know you have these
balls and sticks and you're sort of
arranging them and what possible
Arrangements can you make and and
usually people will say well we're going
to just study these particular 10
molecules but I think it's more
interesting to think well you know you
know we got this construction kit you
can get these chemical construction kits
it's like well what could you make and
then what characteristics does this have
well that molecule is probably not in
the textbook the molecule you make by
just sticking things together probably
not in the textbook maybe nobody ever
cared about that molecule maybe that
molecule is somewhere in the databases
of molecules you go look it up see what
its properties are it's like okay that's
what that molecule is and then you make
another one you look that one up I I I
kind of feel that that's a more at least
for maybe it's just somebody with my
Turn of Mind mind that's a more
interesting kind of way of seeing what's
the global picture of what's happening
in chemistry rather than just there's
this random molecule with this fact
about it this one with this fact about
it and it all seems kind of random and
really just an exercise in in uh in kind
of memorizing things rather than a um
rather than something where there's a
bigger picture involved I I think uh you
know it doesn't help that in chemistry
even the specification of molecules can
be very complic ated thing because for
example if you've got this graph that's
just all these carbon atoms and they're
arranged in all these different ways or
whatever else it's like what is the name
of that graph well you know you can
um
uh you know you could you sort of at a
computational level it's pretty easy to
specify the graph but if you want to
make a word for that graph it's like
well how do you describe the fact that
there are these two molecules at the end
here then a branch and then this other
one that's connected there and you end
up with these you know
dbo hexo whatever it is these long long
long kind of constructions of words that
represent graphs the graphs are very
easy to draw very easy to to see what
they are but but turning that into a
word is a big sort of conventional uh
pain and and and it doesn't make the
subject look good that you end up with
these incredibly complicated looking
words okay as a graph the molecule is
something pretty straightforward as a
word
it's this long thing that goes on for
half a line that you have to kind of
decode it's a little bit in modern times
although I don't think they teach this a
lot in in elementary chemistry there are
these things called smile strings which
are much more systematic ways to sort of
specify the the graph structure of a
molecule I'm not sure why they don't
teach those why they why they insist on
I think they insist on still teaching
these conventional kind of names
molecules I mean it's sure if you want
to look up I'm sure you can look things
up by smile strings now days um and uh
you know it's just one of those things
where it's a it's a it's a piece of the
history of the field but it's not
terribly interesting it's something
which makes the whole thing seem very
arbitrary so I I and I think the other
thing to understand about chemistry is
that certain things are known and a lot
is not known you know if you say in
detail how does this chemical reaction
happen it's like nobody knows and I
think the fact that one then has certain
things one does know that one can kind
of identify yep we know this we know
this we know this for me at least
learning chemistry if somebody had said
look we just don't know how you know you
can imagine how these molecules can
crash into each other and maybe
sometimes they stick and sometimes they
don't and you can see that's a
complicated problem but just saying oh
we can work this out in terms of this
rate constant and this and that and uh
you know this free energy thing and and
so on it's it's not to me it just all
seems it it seems very hard it seems
like you're you're kind of floating in
this world things that you don't
understand and the issue is do you not
understand them because you just didn't
get far enough in the chemistry textbook
or you don't understand them because
nobody understands them and the fact is
in a lot of chemistry the the underlying
principles come from physics and quite
well understood but exactly how they're
put together in chemistry is something
where there just isn't an easy way to
say it and to sort of just keep on
poking at these things where well yes we
happen to be able to say something about
this we happen to be able to say
something about that I think it's a
useful thing to just say uh you know
it's it's there's a lot we don't know
there's a lot that's that's that's
really can't be figured out hasn't been
figured out and is in fact
computationally fundamentally difficult
to figure out and so we have to just
poke at these individual things where we
can be excited that we do know this
particular fact about chemistry even
though the general story would can't
tell so anyway that's what that's what I
would do in uh in my very very ID ratic
approach to trying to explain explain
chemistry all right well thanks for
joining me for our last live stream of
2023 and I look forward to uh talking
with you again in the new year happy New
Year to everybody see you then
bye